[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY WALKER: All right.
Hi, my name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm a developer platform
engineer here at Google.
And I wanted to talk to
you a little bit about how
I use Kotlin to make watch
face creation much easier
on WEAR OS.
So, watch faces are
kind of hard right now.
And you have to write about
600 plus lines of code.
It's not like a nice app you
do in Android or WEAR OS,
where you can declare a lot
of the UI in an XML format.
You actually have to
manually paint everything.
And then you have to
include a bunch of code just
to make sure when
your in ambient mode
you're not hurting
the battery life.
So, I was trying
to think of ways
to improve this and last
year at I/O we announced
official support for Kotlin.
So I started
thinking, how could I
use Kotlin to make this easier?
And I did convert
the whole thing
to Kotlin, which did reduce
the code lines a lot.
But I found something
else with Kotlin
that made it even more cool.
And that was
something called DSL.
So, what is Kotlin DSL?
The best way to understand what
a domain specific language is,
is to compare it to a
regular programming language.
So, again, domain
specific language.
That, for me,
didn't really help.
But, if you compare it to,
like, a general programming
language like Kotlin
or Java, where
you have a bunch of keywords,
you have classes, methods,
and you make a nice big app,
the opposite, on the other side,
is the DSL, which focuses on
a specific task or domain.
So, it forgoes a
lot of functionality
and lets you just do
that specific task.
You've actually probably used
external DSL and not even
realized it.
For example, SQL.
For manipulating databases.
That's a DSL.
So, it's regular expressions
for manipulating strings.
So, they each have an
independent syntax.
They reduce a lot
of functionality.
You don't need, like, methods
or a class to make them work.
You're not going to write a full
on application in them either.
At least, I hope not.
For SQL, the first
keyword kind of
indicates, as a verb,
what you're going to do.
Maybe you're going to Select
or you're going to Update.
The disadvantage here,
as you probably know,
is you have to put that
as a string literal.
So, you have to pray and hope
that you spelled everything
right until runtime
and then maybe it fails
and you have to hack through it
and figure out what's going on.
So, with Kotlin DSL it actually
extracts that out of the string
and it puts it
right in your code.
You can have type
checking, you can
have code hints, and
all that good stuff
that comes with your IDE.
So, now that you kind of
have an idea of what it is,
I'd like to show you two
structures really quick.
And I use the
latter, but there's
one called "chained
method calls,"
and the other one is
"nesting of lambdas."
So, recognizing DSL
is really subjective.
You know it when you see it.
So, let's see some.
So, this is Kotlin DSL for SQL.
You could probably look at
it, and if you know SQL,
you can understand
it right away.
And it's all verbs like
Slice, and then I Select All,
and then I Group By, then I
Order By, and then I Limit.
And this is all type checked
and you get code hinting,
so you don't spell
anything wrong.
And this is pretty great
and it's understandable.
This is DSL.
But the DSL for the watch
face, which I really liked,
was a "nested lambda" structure.
So, this is to
create a watch face.
You can see right away, Create
A Watch Face is the verb.
But if you look at my structure,
you don't know anything--
you may not know anything
about making a watch face.
But you can probably understand
what's going on right away.
Analog watch face.
OK, it's not digital
so it has arms.
Colors.
OK, I can figure that out.
The dimensions for the hand,
the hour hand, the minute hand,
the second hand.
OK, I understand that.
Watch face background image.
So, that's all.
It's very declarative.
So you can kind of
understand right away.
And this is all type
checked and I get code hints
and all that good stuff.
And in the end I get this nice
little watch face with no work.
Now the 600 lines, they
didn't all go away.
I put them in a helper
class and combined it
with the more important class.
It interprets this DSL.
But if you're
making a watch face
you only need to
know about the DSL.
So, what's next?
This is kind of an experiment
I did as a code lab.
So check out the code lab.
It'll only take you 15 minutes
to make a new watch face.
Just search for
Kotlin watch face code
lab-- jeez, that's really long.
Just search for Google code lab.
And it's under the WEAR
OS, or search under Kotlin.
You can see how to
make a watch face.
And you can see the code--
the source code for how I made
the transition between DSL
and interpreted it into
a nice little watch face.
But more importantly,
hopefully now you're
a little bit interested
in DSL and say,
hey, I could use this
in one of my projects
to make it a little bit better.
Or you can go out and use
something like the DSL for SQL.
There's one for testing.
And one that's more
similar to mine.
You can even do HDML in your
Kotlin coding, type checked.
Which is kind of what
I modeled mine after.
So, thank you for the talk--
letting me talk.
And hopefully I've
kind of got you
a little bit interested in DSL.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]